nos dicen que carla compró una pulsera
pagó 72 centavos de impuestos de venta
por la pulsera la tasa del impuesto de
venta es de 6% cuál es el precio
original de la pulsera antes del
impuesto pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo pues no pensemos en la manera
de calcular el impuesto de venta el
impuesto de venta
será igual a la tasa del impuesto de
venta solo le llamaré tasa por el precio
original
y qué es lo que sabemos de estos datos
bueno nos dicen cuál es el impuesto de
venta son 72 centavos y lo voy a
escribir aquí 72 centavos es igual a la
tasa del impuesto de venta que también
nos la dan y que es 6% por el precio
original y esto es lo que nos preguntan
el precio original le voy a llamar p
para abreviar aquí la tenemos ahora
tenemos una ecuación bastante sencilla
voy a reescribir todo como decimales así
que tenemos 0.72 es igual a 6% que es
igual a 6 sobre 100 que es lo mismo que
6 centésimas 0.06 6 centésimas por p
ahora podemos dividir los dos lados en
36 centésimas para obtener el precio
original
hagámoslo muy bien del lado derecho
tenemos pe y del lado izquierdo tenemos
72 centésimas divididas entre 6
centésimas
es igual a 12 12 por 6 es igual a 72 6
centésimas por 12 es igual a 72
centésimas de modo que esto es igual a
cuál es el precio original de la pulsera
antes del impuesto es de 12 pesos y lo
podemos verificar el 6 por ciento de 12
pesos 0.06 por 12 es sin duda 72
centavos hagamos otro ejemplo una tienda
tiene un descuento del 25 por ciento en
calcetines con este descuento el precio
de un par de calcetines es igual a 34
puntos 50 cuál es el precio original de
los calcetines una vez más pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo estos
ejemplos son muy útiles porque nos
encontramos todo el tiempo con esto
cuando vamos de compras o cuando
tratamos de calcular un impuesto así que
piensen en esto pueden calcular el
precio original de los calcetines muy
bien vamos a escribirlo de la misma
forma en que lo hicimos la última vez
digamos entonces que el precio original
menos el descuento del 25% lo escribo
aquí abajo menos el 25% del precio
original
es igual a 34 50 porque 34.50 incluye el
descuento ahora podemos calcular el
precio original una forma de pensar en
esto es decir que esto es el 100% del
precio original o una vez el precio
original menos el 25% del precio
original es igual a esto bueno 100 por
ciento de algo menos 25 por ciento de
ese algo es igual a 75 por ciento de
nuestro precio original
esta es la razón por la que la gente usa
letras como variables para no tener que
estar escribiendo todo una y otra vez
esto es igual a 34.50 ahora para obtener
el precio original
simplemente dividimos los dos lados
entre 75% y 75% es lo mismo que 75 sobre
100 o 75 centésimas así que podemos
dividir los dos lados entre setenta y
cinco centésimas del lado izquierdo
estos son equivalentes así que aquí nos
queda el precio original ahora sólo
tengo que calcular el resultado voy a
multiplicar estos dos números por 100 y
esto será igual a 3.450 dividido entre
75 hice esto para deshacerme de los
decimales esencialmente movía el punto
decimal dos posiciones a la derecha
multiplicando el numerador y el
denominador por 100 ahora veamos cuántas
veces cabe 75 en 3.450 vamos a ver 75 no
caben tres
no caben 34
y en 345 cuánto es esto cuatro veces
cuatro por cinco es igual a 20 4 por 7
es igual a 28 2 300 luego restamos
obtenemos 45 bajamos el 0 450 75 cabe en
450 6 veces 6 por 5 es igual a 30 6 por
7 es igual a 42 más 3 sin duda es 45 y
tenemos suerte de no tener residuos lo
que tenemos aquí es igual a 46 pesos
nuestro precio original es 46 le
restamos un cuarto o 25% y nos quedan 34
puntos 50 y esto tiene sentido siempre
es bueno tomar nuestra respuesta y
regresar a ver si tiene sentido si de
alguna manera obtienes 460 y le quitas
25% para obtener 34.50 entonces dices
eso no está bien o se obtienes 4 y le
quitas 25% para obtener 34.50
tampoco tiene sentido pero 46 suena bien
incluso podrías calcularlo cuánto es el
25 por ciento de 46 restarlo a 46 y
deberías obtener 34.50 terminamos